so quantum random number generation
is the topic for today so this is
something that yay and i have been
working on for the last few years
and uh it's been kind of a centerpiece
for the qip research group
at the university of michigan and right
around the middle of last year we
started to have a critical mass of ideas
and found
found some results so uh the
the the outcome of the work consists of
several performance results for
um device independent random number
generation but in the process of proving
these results we came up with some new
techniques that were hopeful we'll find
applications
elsewhere so the main goal of this talk
is to
communicate the techniques
so i'll start by giving some background
on quantum random number generation uh
talk about what was already known before
and then um talk about the uh techniques
that we use to get our results and they
split
naturally into two categories there's so
since we're doing device independence we
need to handle measurements and we need
to handle states
and they're basically fairly independent
techniques
for doing and the main
the main state of the talk is going to
be covering those two
those two parts and then at the end i'll
talk about the relationship between our
work
and the work of kaimin chung yayanshi
and jaudy wu
on randomise amplification which is a
closely related problem
and then i'll close with some open
problems
okay so to begin with the general
scenario that we're looking at
this is a variant of the scenario that's
appeared in a lot of talks
so far this week the basic idea is
we have a classical user who wants to
generate truly random numbers
so what she's looking for is um
a collection of numbers that is nearly
uniformly random up to some negligible
error
and is unknown to any outside party
so we're setting the bar pretty high and
in addition to that
she's a strictly classical user and
does not trust quantum operations at all
so we
we go all the way to the extreme in
terms of in terms of trust and say
this classical user alice will not trust
quantum operations unless she can
somehow verify them through strictly
classical means
and the basic way to do that is her
possessing
a device split into multiple components
she does manipulations of the components
so as to verify that what's going on
inside of them is what it's supposed to
be
and we're imagining an adversarial
scenario where
there's a user who has inside knowledge
about the behavior of the devices
and may even have entanglement with
those devices and whatever protocol we
come up with
has to guard against any adversarial
strategies
by that by that person
so here's a basic protocol for
generating random numbers and this comes
from roger kovic's
thesis from 2006. the idea is that we
exploit violations of bell inequalities
to get random numbers
what does that mean how you mean about
the devices can
the adversary send messages between the
device
what is the exactly oh yeah so that's a
good question so
so no the adversary is not allowed to
communicate with devices once the
protocol has started
we do a lot for the possibility that he
can do arbitrary manipulations of the
devices before the
protocol begins so you can establish
entanglement
but once the protocol is started there's
no communication allowed with the
adversary
yep also are you assuming quantum
mechanics or no signaling or
we assume quantum mechanics yeah and an
interesting direction to explore is
whether the same security proof could be
reproduced just based on non-segment
any other questions about the setup
okay so so the basic uh protocol is this
so alice generates some a small amount
of initial randomness
we assume that she has the ability to do
that and
then she uses that initial randomness to
play non-local games with this
multi-part device
and during the non-local games she
shields one device from the other so
that they can't communicate
and then if the boxes exhibit an average
score at the
non-local game that is impossible for a
classical device if it gets into
the quantum realm then she concludes
that the
devices must be exhibiting some kind of
quantum behavior
so she concludes that the outputs of the
device are at least partially random
she applies a classical randomness
extractor using some additional
uh self-generated randomness
and then um presumes that what comes out
of that extractor
is a collection of nearly uniformly
random bits
so the effect is randomness expansion
small collection of randomness
transformed into a larger collection of
randomness
so that was kobach's proposal however he
didn't prove that it works
um so it remained an open question to
actually give the necessary security
proofs
to show that an approach like this would
work and also to come up with protocols
that optimize
this approach
so a lot of papers over the last several
years have appeared on this problem and
also
the closely related problem of device
independent quantity distribution
there were multiple ones that addressed
the case of
a unentangled adversary so
just assuming that nobody has
entanglement with the boxes
and trying to prove that the
outputs of the devices are uniformly
random just from a classical
perspective so there were multiple
papers that
did that and the rates gradually
increased and uh and they got up to
exponential exponential rate from the
initial c
to the ultimate output and then
the first and so as far as i know the
only
truly quantum secure randomness
expansion
protocol is due to thomas and umesh
from 2012. so they have an exponentially
expanding
protocol that is secure even if the
adversary
is entangled with the devices
so when we learned about this result the
um the next frontier that we saw was
robustness so this is an example of a
non-robust result meaning
if the device performs perfectly at the
say the chsh game or whatever non-local
game you're
using um then it will
pass the protocol with probability
approaching one but if there's
a constant rate of error even if it's a
small conservative error
it will um pass the protocol with
probability approaching zero
as the number of iterations increases so
the next frontier
for us was looking for a protocol that
will permit some uh
non-zero level of error in the device
used and we'll
in spite of this error still be able to
output nearly uniformly random bits
at the end
so first i'll say a little bit about
why this seemed to us to be challenging
so the basic idea is we have some kind
of
non-local game let's say it's the chsh
game
and
there's an optimal quantum score that we
know of for this game so in the case of
chsh
that's root 2 over 2 that's the best
that a quantum
device can do and then
there are results that say
that if the exhibited score the average
score uh
shown by a device over many iterations
converges to
root two over two
um as the number of iterations increases
then you can make strong conclusions
about the behavior of the device
so for example the multi-shot rigidity
theorem of right shot anger in vasarani
allows us to say that if the
convergence occurs at a certain way
then we can conclude that most of the
time the device is exhibiting near
perfect behavior meaning it's doing
the the unique optimal quantum strategy
in order to
produce its outputs and that's not just
over one iteration but over
multiple consecutive iterations and
so in particular that would imply that
most of the time the outputs are
actually nearly uniformly random and you
don't even need to extract them they're
already
nearly uniformly random
so so the question is what happens when
we start to weaken the initial
assumption
what happens if we allow root 2 over 2
minus
c for some c so if we allow
a constant level of error then can we
control
what the device is actually doing
with this weaker assumption and the
reason i always found that difficult was
because
this allows for a constant amount of
variation
in both the state and the measurements
of the device and it's a little hard to
predict how that's going to affect
the ultimate results of the protocol so
there are
cases where we know how to handle this
so like
in the unentangled case
so we can say for example
that um say we set a slightly lower bar
here
say take like
root 2 over 2 minus 2c
and i say that a device is good
if it's expected performance the css h
is above that level
and it's bad if it's below
so then the goal is
to prove that
good devices
generate randomness
and bad devices tend to fail the
protocol
so in the unentangled case
it's possible to set up an argument
along those lines so you can look at
the tree of possible inputs and outputs
to the device
so we look at the possible input outputs
for the first round there's some
branching
and then outputs for the second round
there's more branching
and so basically in this tree
each path represents a certain input
output sequence
and you can make claims along the lines
of you can identify certain paths as
being
good and certain paths as being bad the
bad ones are where the average
expected score at cssh is below that
that level and divide those up into two
and prove security based on that
division
so there it's a strictly classical
argument so classical security results
will apply
on the other hand if you have say
quantum and you're in the
memoryless case
then you've got a case where you have
your device
and it's entangled with our adversary
and we're calling charlie
and in the memoryless case it's fairly
simple you don't need to worry about
dependencies between inputs and outputs
and what you can do is
you can identify a certain subspace
of charlie's as being
the good subspace and then the
complementary subspace is
the bad subspace
and basically if charlie measures in
some basis that's compatible with these
subspaces
if he finds it in a good subspace then
the devices can exhibit good behavior
and you can prove security
and if he finds it in a bad subspace
then the device is going to exhibit bad
behavior and the probability of failing
will tend to one
so in both cases you're okay where this
gets really hard
at least from our perspective is trying
to put these two together somehow
and trying to somehow juggle both the
dependence on inputs and outputs
and the uh the quantum environment
because
you know just trying to take into
account the fact that charlie can
measure along any basis
and then somehow trying to prove both of
these conclusions at once
we always found to be very difficult
so the ultimate result that we came up
with was a slightly more indirect
approach
that basically sidestepped all this
complexity and just
prove that the states that result from
this protocol are random
even if we can't completely understand
what they look like
so here are results so we have an
exponential randomness expansion
protocol with full quantum security
and then the following features which as
far as we know are all new
um we have robustness so there's a
certain
constant level of noise that can be
tolerated by the protocol
and we have cryptographic security so
this is a
crucial property for any applications to
cryptography
if we're going to use bits in
cryptograph and in a cryptographic
application
we need to have the fact that the error
term vanishes
at a super polynomial rate in the number
of iterations
of the protocol and a nice
byproduct of our theory is that we can
prove that as well
and then constant quantum memory
um since we don't uh
we don't have to separate the devices
completely we can allow them to
communicate in between rounds
they only need to hold a constant amount
of entanglement at any given time
and then a large class of games is
allowed chsh is one but there are many
others
for which the same level of security
will apply
so out of this we get um some uh some
nice results so
benefits of full quantum security which
have been observed before
um are one one is that we can get a
quantum key distribution protocol
so in the quantum key distribution
scenario we have two parties
communicating over insecure channel
you need to be able to guard against the
fact that an adversary might eavesdrop
and might entangle with
their information and we're able to do
that we're also able to do it with
a small initial seed if we have a
protocol that expands randomness
and does qtd at the same time
and then in conjunction with chung shi
wu which i'm going to talk a little bit
more about
later we have some more results on
composition
so the method for unbounded expansion
from a constant number of devices
so the first result along these lines
was proved by kudron and yoon
and that's going to be talked about in
the in the next talk and
we also have unbounded expansion from
any single mid-entropy source
so not only can we expand from
a uniformly random seed but we can also
expand from
any source that is unpredictable it
doesn't need to be
uniformly random and a constant number
of devices
uh no actually and that's a good point
so so one
open avenue is to try to do this with a
constant number of devices um the
chunksy wood protocol
has an expanding number of devices
depending on what error term uh
okay so so that's the advertisement
portion of the talk any questions at
this point
okay so um so i'll talk about uh
the proof techniques
so the
um the idea that i've kind of identified
as the centerpiece of our results is
this idea of forcing trust
and it's the idea it's sort of it's a
change in perspective
on security proofs that leads to
some the mathematics that actually
enabled us to get these performance
results
and the idea is we're no longer
imagining that we are passively
um checking the behavior of the device
in our protocol or
actually doing when we when we use
kobach's
protocol or some variant callbacks
protocol
is that we are forcing partially trusted
behavior
from an untrusted device so even though
the behavior of individual components is
completely untrusted
we're able to simulate the behavior of a
device that is actually
partially trusted i'll show you what i
mean by that
so forcing trust is the the measurement
side of our theory
and the other side is the uh the state
side so first we try to control the
measurements
then we try to control the theory and
split it up that way
so here is an example of a randomness
expansion
protocol and um i got this from
a paper on classical security by kujon
vitiken yoon
and it's closely related to the vasrani
amvidic protocol
and the basic idea is we are doing uh
kobek's approach to random number
generation
but we're doing it in a conservative way
so we don't um
just play the chsh game over and over
again instead what we do is
sometimes we play the chsh game
and sometimes we merely give the device
a fixed input strength we just give it
zero and zero
so this classical controller receives a
bit and depending on the value of the
bit
he either generates inputs random inputs
for the chsh game
or he generates a fixed uh string
and in the former case he records
whether or not the game is won
in the latter case he merely takes the
output of
the first device and passes that along
so the result is we have a device group
here that essentially accepts a single
bit
and returns another bit
and then in all these all the randomness
expansion protocols i've seen there's
always a final
step where we decide whether the
device has performed up to standard
so we check whether the failure rate was
low enough
in this case i guess it should be
something like
uh one half minus root two over four or
something like that or
or a little possibly a little bit above
that
um so we have one half minus root two
over four plus c
and as long as it's below that level we
say the protocol succeeded
would generate random numbers if it's
above that level
then we say the protocol has not
succeeded we abort and we give no output
okay so this was known so we take a
um a slightly different perspective on
what's going on
in this uh in this protocol
so let's look at what this device group
is doing if we consider it just as one
unit so any classical process can be
sorry any quantum process could be
considered as
performing some kind of measurement on
some kind of state
so in this case what we have is we have
two
unknown binary measurements that are
taking place in whatever
state is inside these boxes we don't
know what the measurements are we also
don't know what the state is but we can
still make
some conclusions so
when you say two quantum devices now
oh sorry i should i meant to say um a
single device with two components
where one is whatever happens when you
give the input zero
that's one component and the other is
whatever happens when
you actually previously just integrated
yeah so you could think of it that way
so you could think of this as one
um one big device that accepts a zero
one and depending on that performs one
measurement or another
so there's there's a measurement
corresponding to one which is the
measurement corresponding to the chsh
gain
so for example tax measurement includes
you know generate a pair of random
inputs feed them to the devices devices
do what they want
collect the pair of outputs and then
check if the condition is satisfied or
not
and that's actually your own yeah
exactly yeah that's what i had in mind
yeah
yeah so so when i when i talk about this
this whole unit as performing a
measurement i'm including the playing of
the css game
in that yeah so there's a random choice
there's some individual measurements
collectively the effect of that is what
i have in mind now
and what is what now from the variables
there
so um so what we're so we're saying is
so
this first component here is performing
some kind of measurement on a quantum
state
and i'm saying that measurement is
represented by these operators here
okay so that's the the box by the
adversary the one box is the left
measurement
yeah right so our um uh yeah
the box is generated by the adversary
yeah so this this one corresponds to
the box on the left and this one
corresponds to the box on the right
okay and then you have some box around
that decides whether we do ch
is h or just zero measurement yeah so
these these classical controllers are
what have the effect of that
so this is so the uh the classical
controller here does
the procedure that was on the previous
slide in terms of choosing whether to do
chsh
or just generate a fixed pair
transcended to the devices
is just what happens in the left green
box
yeah right so this is yeah what happens
here
so mi is what this is both and one plus
am i half this one
so yeah yeah
yeah yeah so what i've written here so
far just addresses the individual
components
okay so we have a mathematical way of
writing out
the um the individual measurements made
by
these specific components and then
since this is a binary measurement
there's a very nice way we can write
what's going on here and all of this i'd
have to say
particularly the binary measurements and
i don't know how to generalize it beyond
that although it would be an interesting
avenue to explore
so um if we choose an appropriate basis
and we may not know what the basis is
but that's okay we know that under some
basis
um the uh the measurements
performed on input 0 and input 1 in say
this device
this component can be written
in this form they just have a diagonal
block form and then
there are some unknowns in the second
measurement which are unit length
complex numbers
which i'm calling xj so if you're
familiar with jordan's lemon so the idea
is
we have um two projections in a high
dimensional space
and these numbers here measure the
angles between
those two projections and the xj is
basically completely specified the
measurement behavior of
the first component
and then um we can come up with a
similar expression for
the measurements performed by the other
component with a different set of
parameters
so then
now if we do what i was alluding to
before and look at this whole
group of devices as a single device
and just look at it as something that is
collectively accepting a single bit
measuring a state and then producing an
output then we can write down an
expression for what
the collective measurement actually
looks like so we have this bipartite
system here
and then there's a binary povm that's
taking
two possible binary periods that can
take place on
that bipartite system and we can write
that out just
in terms of the parameters x and y
so uh the measurement that takes place
on zero
will have blocks that look like this all
the entries are known
and then on input one the blocks will
look like this so
the um the entries are not known but we
can
constrain them based on what we know
about xj
and uh and yk so here to write out the
segments you're using the fact that this
is
yeah right yeah so that's where that
comes in yeah so so
this is the part where we're factoring
in exactly where we're factoring in
the uh the effect of the chsh game so
this classical controller here
generates random numbers gives them to
these devices and that
shows up in this expression here
so basically this arises from it is a
linear combination of tensor products of
the original measurements that we were
looking at so collectively
these two devices are performing a
measurement on the bipartite system
that is a sum of intensive products of
the mis and the n
j's and if we were to actually just
write that out
then that's where this expression comes
from
the shape of the matrix does not depend
on the
shape meaning the diagonal block form
yeah right yeah yeah it's important that
since we've gotten it down to this point
so the overall reverse diagonal
structure um
is is always the same whatever game
we're using here
um so the only thing that's particularly
the chsh gain
are the coefficients that appear here
but yeah they all come from cssh
okay so now we can actually we can get
something from this so even though
all these numbers are unknown um
there are constraints on the possible
values that are taking place here
so this can't be just any measurement it
has to be a measurement that can be
expressed in this form where x j and y k
are unit length complex numbers and we
can deduce something from that
we can show that the measurement a1 can
always be decomposed
into a direct sum into a weighted sum of
t and u
where t perfectly anti-commutes with the
other measurement
a0
and proving that is just a matter of
manipulations of complex numbers
so there's some fixed constant lambda
which
just depends on the fact that we're
using the cssh game doesn't depend on
what strategy we're using
such that we can always break a1 down
into these two components
where one of them is perfectly
anti-commuting
with the zero measurement
so this is what i'm calling forcing
trust and here's why
the behavior of this collective device
is that on a0 it does something trusted
and then on
input one it does one of three behaviors
either it performs a perfectly
anti-commuting measurement one that
perfectly anti-commutes with the zero
measurement
or it does something unknown or
it just outputs a random coin flip
so these options basically correspond to
the sum ends in this expression
if i wanted to make it complete i could
add plus 0
times 1 minus root 2 over 2 to account
for the coin flip part
so what the expression effectively
represents is a random decision made by
this device at each round independent
random decision
about which measurement to perform and
the critical fact is that
one of these measurements is a
completely trusted
measurement it's one that gives a
perfectly anti-commuting measurement
with the uh the zero measurement
so far there's there's no assumption on
this device actually passing through
to safety yeah exactly right yeah so
this is why i call this forcing trust
because it's not a matter of testing the
device to see if it's doing
what we want it to do it's more like
it's compelling the device to do
what we want to do and there's no test
taking place we don't pass it or fail it
we just say we do these measurements and
we know that there's a
nonzero probability that it's going to
do what it's supposed to do
um is this outputting a random coin flip
are you saying it you can further
decompose this a1 operator into
this random coin flip part or are you
adding it
on to a1 so it uh
it comes from the expression that we
have there
so if i want to make the
expression a little bit more complete i
could add a term
so what we could say is that a1
is equal to lambda times t
plus root two over two minus lambda
times u plus
one minus root two over two
times zero
and basically this is saying that with
probability 1 minus
root 2 over 2 the measurement performed
is
identity plus 0 over 2
identity minus 0 over 2.
so just as t and u will determine
measurement behaviors
so too does this zero over here
determine a measurement behavior
and that measurement behavior is simply
leave the state alone
and output a random coin flip
mathematically that's
what it comes down to if these
devices inside are quite totally bad and
they
say they always output zero uh then you
still say that we get one
randomness out of them that's yeah yeah
so
it's a little tricky so i would still
say that but the thing is so this is
it's a noisy simulation of a trusted
measurement and the fact is sometimes
the noise is going to
cancel out the trusted part so if it
were a case where the devices were just
behaving
deterministically this
this statement here would still be true
but the thing is this unknown
measurement here could basically be
cancelling out the effect of
the anti-commuting measurement but not
of the random country
so you're saying there's still some
randomness happening but that can't be
if oh i don't know where it would come
from actually there will always be in
this case there will always be some
randomness because even if
the devices are exhibiting um even if
their
individual components are exhibiting a
deterministic strategy they'll still be
some randomness in whether or not they
win the chsh game
so say they always output a zero that
means that three quarters of the time
they're going to win the chsh game and
one quarter because there's random input
initiations
and where does that come from then that
comes from the the classical controller
yeah so the uh there is some randomness
that's generated by
that uh controller there
then i'm a bit confused but the overall
goal is i mean we wanted to produce
randomness
right right that produces this already
yeah right so so this by itself doesn't
necessarily show that we've successfully
produced randomness
so there will be some more work um that
we'll need to do in order to do that
and that's when we start looking at
actually testing the device
so the basic idea is we're we're
eventually going to need to start
looking at cases where we need to show
that
the this measurement here when it's
applied
tends to give uh a biased outcome
and um we use that so when that takes
place then we know
that um then we're able to conclude that
some randomness is coming out of the
protocol
because uh some anti-commuting
measurements are are being applied i
don't know what the device is that you
construct in the end
because now it sounds that you have a
classical controller
that is trusted to produce randomness
and you use this to in the end
produce randomness right right yeah so
so the ultimate result is we come up
with a protocol
where there's a certain cost there's a
certain amount of randomness that's put
in and then there's a certain amount of
randomness come
that comes out and ultimately what we
prove is more
randomness comes out then it goes in
okay so it's a constant stream input
but then you can for example like reuse
some earlier output
for later input so uh no i wouldn't say
that no but i would just say
the the total number of extractable bits
that comes out at the end of the
protocol
is more than the amount that we put in
okay
and it's true it's not something that's
clear from this analysis that that takes
some
some additional work so this by itself
doesn't necessarily show that we have
randomness expansion
um but yeah with some additional work
we're able to show that the cost of
simulating this device
is outweighed by the ultimate benefit of
the protocol
all right so
the ultimate result is we have untrusted
devices completely untrusted devices
simulating partially trusted measurement
devices
okay and so um
the the second part i'll go through a
little bit more
quickly but this is the part where we
exploit the
trusted measurements to get randomness
from
a an unknown state and in this case we
don't know anything about
we assume that we don't know anything
about the state we can only control the
measurements
and we somehow have to get randomness
from
that state so i'm going to set up a new
protocol which is sort of a variant of
the one we looked at before and the
basic idea is
we now assume that alice has the ability
to perform
completely trusted measurements because
we know we can at least do that in
a noisy fashion so we're going to go all
the way and assume that she can do
perfectly
trusted measurements and
the state is unknown and alice will
perform anti-commuting measurements on
it
while guarding against any possible
eavesdropping by an entangled
adversary
this is what i think is another one of
the insights of
our project in that we alter the
um the style of the random number
generation
protocols in that we don't have an all
or nothing
abort or succeed condition
so typically you know as we saw before
at the end of a protocol
the user says okay the device is
performed at this level i will either
succeed or i will avoid it's an all or
nothing condition
and i always found that too difficult to
work with in the analysis because
there's this global event at the end of
the protocol we have to condition on
this global event
it's very hard to predict how that's
going to affect the distribution
of the device when we do that
conditioning
so we change it a little bit
so assuming that alice is
making measurements on this unknown
state and charlie has
there's a possibility for error and
there's possibility to disguise
adversarial behavior in that era
what alice does is um
so she's expecting she
the prescribed behavior of the device is
it's supposed to have
a state in it that will always give
output zero
when uh the measurement zero slash one
is performed
so here we're imagining basically that
there's a single qubit in the device
that's being measured
either in plus minus basis or zero one
basis because any anti-commuting case
can be reduced to that so the prescribed
behavior is it's never supposed to give
the output one it's only supposed to
give the output zero
and alice runs the protocol using random
coin flips to choose which measurements
to do
and then if she ever gives an output uh
gets an output of one
she won't give up on the device because
that wouldn't be rude up the robust
what she does is she flips an additional
coin
and adds the results of that coin flip
straight into
the output
and she considers that part of the same
round so this is the
this is the output of the first round
the second round and those two letters
would be the output of the third round
and the result is
that she uh
so there's a certain amount of
randomness going in and a certain amount
of randomness
going out and we can compare the two
and i'll just skim this part since i'm
low on time
but basically we have uncertainty
principles
which apply to situations like this so
there's a situation where
we have some conditional behavior
conditional additional behavior
by the classical user based on the
outputs of the device
so when we look at that in in terms of
collision entropy this is a expression
for collision entropy
the output of the protocol in a single
iteration would be measured by this
expression
trace of rho plus squared plus rho minus
squared plus rho zero squared
plus one half times row one squared
and the one half corresponds to the
auxiliary coin flip that alice does
to uh compensate when the the device
exhibits the wrong behavior
and so we proved this and i'm i have not
seen
uncertainty principles so far in the
literature they're in this form
i'm curious if anybody else has i've
seen uh tripartite
uncertainty principles that address the
uncertainty of anti-community
measurements in a tripod setting
but in this case we have bipartite with
a waiting
term and and we think that may be new
and there's
probably a class of principles like this
that could be proven
so anyway the result of that
is if we assume that for the moment that
the adversary's system is completely
mixed
then the uncertainty principle says we
get one plus k bits per round
and then the number of bits going in so
this is the part is referring to before
we balance the number of bits going in
versus the number of bits coming out
the number of bits going into the
protocol depends on how noisy the device
is
so if it fails with probability f at any
given iteration
where a failure is outputting one
uh then the average number of bits is
going to be one plus f
per round and provided
that f is smaller than the constant k
that showed up in our uncertainty
principle
then we've achieved some randomness
expansion we've achieved a linear rate
of randomness expansion
a little bit more comes out and then
goes in
so that's an initial step that's sort of
just like the the match that
lights the fire and then based on that
we evolved it into a more advanced
protocol change the distribution of the
coins going in don't make them fair
coincides make them biased because those
are easy to easier to generate with less
cost
change the measure of randomness instead
of using collision entropy
use renny entropy instead of using
exponent 2 use 1 plus q
where q is the bias of the coins
and then basically just evolve from
there
until we get exponential randomness
expansion from partially trusted
measurements
against an all-powerful adversary
and then the final step is completed by
what we saw before
apply the simulation of untrusted
devices and partially trusted devices to
conclude that
the same protocol can be enacted using
multiple completely untrusted client
components
and then we have what we want we have
robust exponential quantum secure
randomness expansion
okay um so then i wanted to say a little
bit about
the randomness amplification problem
that i alluded to
um earlier so this is the uh the results
of chengshi
and wu which was a companion paper to
ours
so this address is the case where alice
doesn't have the ability to flip random
coins
all she has is a non-uniform
non-uniformly distributed
initial source and the question is can
we still get
perfectly or near perfectly uniformly
random numbers
coming out and the surprising answer is
that we can so even if the
both the source and the devices are
imperfect even if they both have
noise you can still get near perfect
randomness
coming in and the basic gist of it is
we apply a classical randomness
extractor
to the non-uniform input and we try out
all possible c's for that extractor
at least one of them you know actually
several but at least one
will give a near uniform input and then
we run that
miller sheet protocol in several copies
on each of the inputs
and we know that at least one of them is
going to work and then we
output the bitwise xor of everything we
get from those copies
so um that's a simple diagram but
there's there's a lot of uh
there's a good deal of technical work
and insight that is required to
prove that it works
okay so yeah so i think uh
it's polynomial many many devices in the
desired era
it depends on depends on a very
important function
in quantum crew classical extractor
of how sharp the seed could be
but it's a function that depends on
the length of the infrasource and the
area that you want to set
okay so it depends on the particular
extractor that you're using
okay uh so that's basically it i just
wanted to mention a couple further
directions that we're interested in so
one of these further directions is very
focused and the other one is very broad
and ambitious but the more focused one
is questions about noise
so we've established that a certain
amount of noise is committed in
exponential randomness expansion
we'd like to know how much we can
actually allow
and this is something that comes down to
it basically all just comes down to
questions about complex numbers like we
were looking at
in the previous segment of the lecture
and um i
i'm curious to see how calculations like
this can be
optimized so basically it amounts to
looking at that coefficient lambda that
we had before for the chsh gain
that is what i call the truss
coefficient of the chsh
gain the bigger that is the more
noise is tolerated in the protocol the
amount of noise tolerate is basically a
linear function of that
so the larger we can make that noise top
more noise tolerance than we get out
i calculated for the ghd gain that the
truss coefficient is at least 0.14
and that tells us that the noise for ghc
is at least
noise tolerance is at least 1.5 percent
but all that's very preliminary and it's
waiting for somebody to
improve the calculations and optimize
them
and then lastly one final plug for
chiang shi wu
they have a scheme for measuring the
performance of
arbitrary randomness amplification and
randomness extraction
procedures and it basically gives us a
direction for the future
so the dream is to have randomness
expansion protocols that maximize
all of these things at once or as many
as we can at once
security quality output length arbitrary
mean entropy source
robustness minimal quantum memory device
efficiency
and computational complexity
and that's it thank you
all right so the uncertainty principle
that you mentioned
when you said it was it was bipartite
but um actually isn't the bipartiteness
from the
from the game in particular so if you
used like a
tripartite game
like ghc for example would you would you
not also get a sort of conclusion about
three parties
i guess you could express it that way
yeah i mean so
the question was so given that in the uh
ultimately what we're doing is is that
we have a tripartite case where we have
a
user with two device components and then
a third person with an entangled system
um is that does that make it a
tripartite uncertainty principle
and um yeah i imagine it's possible that
you could express it that way imagine it
being a little bit more
complicated but maybe maybe by doing
that we could somehow relate it to the
known
tripartite uncertainty principles but
just what what i mean is that
the states i mean the states
that show up in the uncertainty
principle are actually like uh
unipartite in some sense like there's no
tensorfront decomposition
in the states but the the bipartite
tightness comes from the game
decomposition i don't know if i put it
that way so i would i would think of
this
what we have here as an expression for a
bipartite classical quantum state
so what we have is
we have the outputs of a single device
then we have an entangled system e
and basically we've got four possible
outputs so we have a classical register
on those outputs
and then we have a quantum register on
the external environment
and the expression in the numerator
there represents the entropy of that
classical quantum state so that's why i
say it's bipartisan
it says i mean the two parts are the
eavesdropper and the device
the device system is one part each
dropper system is the other part
yeah right exactly okay
and that's thank you